et on va revenir avec vous retirer binky
sur le cas donc d'alla pougatcheva
bonjour gauthier elle je met clairement
en danger oui bien sûr et ça ça prouve
si vous voulez le le danger que tout le
monde en cours parce que à la poubelle
tshuva c'est une artiste qui étaient eux
renommée pendant des décennies je crois
qu'elle a commencé sa carrière en 1965
et elle a été même au sein de l'urss on
peut pas dire que c'était une honte est
à treillis soyez elle n'était pas une
rebelle elle a même représenté l'union
soviétique au fameux concours de
l'eurovision est un concours de chansons
à l'échelon européen
elle chantait si vous voulez des choses
qui était populaire dans la mesure où ça
correspondait à un certain d'états d'âme
mais sans aller trop loin sans dire que
c'était du désespoir alors que parfois
il y avait du désespoir bien sûr quand
on vivait en union soviétique et du coup
elle avait acquis cette notoriété et une
façon d'être presque intouchable et là
que se passe-t-il le déclencheur ça a
été le fait que l a alors deux choses
d'abord elle a assisté aux obsèques de
golgoth chauffe
obsèques très importante pour le monde
dont le monde a préféré focaliser
peut-être sur la reine d'angleterre mais
comme madoff c'était quelque chose
d'important
non alors justement c'était ça
effectivement c'est laid le pouvoir
russe a voulu balayer la chose
rapidement mais ça d'abord ça lui
étaient reprochés et puis deuxièmement
évidemment son mari se garent king qui
était présentateur et ebi musicien qui a
été déclaré comme agent de l'étranger et
ça c'est le sceau infamant quand on
place quand le bois russes placent le ce
saut sur quelqu'un c'est un ferment et
elle a déclaré ben écoutez collet moi
aussi ce sceau infamant je veux être
comme mon mari est effectivement on
pense qu'elle est déjà en dehors de
russie depuis un certain temps est-ce
que ça peut avoir un effet sur le grand
public rétais d'opposition alors oui
parce que si vous voulez dans la perse
dans la perspective où on se pose des
questions c'est cette femme laquelle
beaucoup ont une confiance se disent
tiens il ya quelque chose qui tourne pas
rond et puis on a d'autres si vous
voulez
stooke yahia chine il ya tous ces
gens-là pion qui ont quelque chose à
dire qu'ils sont extrêmement courageux
parce qu'ils ne sont pas organisés et ça
s'éteint l'un des problèmes en russie
c'est que comme on n'a pas connu une
pratique démocratique
on n'a pas la culture de l'association
même de l'association clandestine donc
tous ces gens là se sont peu ou prou
isolé si ce qui rend leur existence très
difficile pour ceux dont on parle
aujourd'hui il y a une chose qui les
protègent relativement c'est précisément
leur notoriété comme chef tous que le
rockeur qui a toujours dit je cite sa
faim en ce moment c'est la patrie les
amis c'est pas embrasser le cube poutine
en permanence olic qui risque gros parce
que ça ça vaut 15 ans de prison minimum
merci beaucoup gauthier rybinski